[Music]
all right rich will hear from the
neighborhood podcast host today on the
show I have the great Dan Harris when we
talk about when we talk about so much we
went on for a long time talk about
meditation we talked about relationships
we talked about balancing ambition with
mindfulness we talked about generosity
so if you're not familiar with Dan he is
a host on Nightline is also one of the
weekend anchors on Good Morning America
he is the man behind the book ten
percent a terrible spot house ten
percent a half-year he's got a new book
out called meditation for fidgety
skeptics and should all check out and
hear more conversation please enjoy it
if you like it
ready to do it yeah alright thanks Dan
thanks for making the time today thank
you
it was either evolved a little chat
worried where did you travel from well
here's here's the thing I had a little
experience confronting my the
limitations of my mindfulness today cuz
I love this I live in the hills above
Malibu Cove in Devon so I was pretty far
away from here
and started driving here like I don't
know twelve thirty or something like
that my plan was to get here meet
Michael here at about 1:30 help him set
up get everything organized and I pulled
into the parking lot here at about 115
looked in the back seat of my truck and
realized that I left all of my podcast
gear at home it's like okay how do I
solve this problem so I called my wife
I'm like I can't believe I did this I'm
such a knucklehead like I look like an
hour away right there's no way I'm gonna
be able to get home get this stuff and
be back here in time to meet you
immediately reflecting on our email
exchange yesterday about where to do
this and making sure that like I'm all
set up when you arrive it's like all
Julia's like you gotta meet you got to
get my stuff and meet me like on halfway
or whatever so I got my that she did it
stepson to do it yeah she did she did it
and it was interesting because this is
the exactly the kind of thing that would
have just put me into an absolute manic
tailspin a couple years ago and I'm not
saying that I handled it with complete
grace today but I actually kept my [ __ ]
together pretty well is like okay this
is what it is
Dan's probably gonna be there when I get
here I'm not gonna be ready to go at
2:30 I'll get there when I get there and
then you know traffic started stacking
up as I got closer and closer to here
with that you know that anxiety notches
up incrementally with each red light
it's like okay it is what it is so I
wouldn't say my blood pressure was at
complete baseline but I give myself like
a b-plus and when normally I would
probably get I probably daddy yes I
think that the Delta between the D and
the B+ actually adds
up to an a in terms of the quality and
quantity of your improvement I mean this
is a case study for why you meditate
it's not that perfection will arise
because perfection is not on offer it's
just being marginally but meaningfully
less of an idiot right and this story
crystallizes the benefits crystal I mean
it's perfect yeah
this thing happens it's your fault right
completely my fault right which is all
my buttons are like you're an idiot you
don't know what you're doing yes yes yes
Guerra plays into okay yeah I see it I
see it I get it
and yet so you didn't handle it like you
know you didn't dance through it like
Fred Astaire
but you handled it much better than you
would have before that's an a yeah and
by the way it will continue to get
better not every day and it won't be a
like straight it's not a linear it's not
a hotness tick but it'll gradually just
kind of go in that direction
yeah I think it will and we'll always
like regress to the mean which is
probably at that 10 percent happier kind
of kind of like trajectory that little
spike was was definitely above the 10%
and and it'll go back down
it'll rubberband a little bit and it's
not a direct reflection of what I did
this morning either
it's just a compounded effect of what
I've been doing over the last couple
years that's right you mean it's not a
it's not a direct we just to clarify
what you said it's not a direct result
of the meditation you did this correct
it's just having meditated for a while
there's actually a bunch of important
things about that you just said first of
all the 10% itself compounds now I don't
know I mean I don't have any math and
medical evidence to back this up but in
my experience the 10% happier goes up
over time because it just compounds like
any good investment the other thing I'd
say is that it is so important that you
point out that it's not a result of the
meditation you did this morning
and a lot of people say you know they
end up meditation and they think well
that was a good or a bad one doesn't
matter
right doesn't matter the only question
to ask yourself at the end of a
meditation you could have been squirming
and miserable the whole time was were
you aware of it
were you mindful of it because you are
not training yourself to be better at
putting yourself into a mental bubble
bath you're training yourself to learn
how to see clearly your own inner chaos
so that it doesn't own you I think
that's a really important observation
and distinction and I kind of analogize
it to you know what it's like to train
for a race why don't you know like one
of the races that I do or to write a
book like you just you have to show up
for it every day and sometimes you show
up and you feel amazing and you hit it
out of the park or the words are just
flowing and other days it's a [ __ ] show
yeah you know it's not working at all
but you show up and you show up the next
day and the cumulative impact of that
consistent application of intention is
really the the most important factor
that's why they call it a practice these
are all practices and in order to
practice anything the first step as you
said is to show up right nothing else
can happen it's funny because you know
when you walked in here today I thought
you seemed slightly less boolean than
the road I was agitated and then when I
went to the bathroom I was like he knows
I'm agitated like I'm running I'm
looping this thing right in my mind he's
like he can tell I'm off-kilter
no no I took it to maybe like I pissed
him off by asking him to come all the
way out here
I'm personalized it you know that I know
but it just tell this is also useful to
unpack because this is the way the mind
works we can personalize it and say it's
the way our minds work but it's really
just the way the mind works every you
know we're all in our own movie and
we're all the stars of our own movie and
whatever is happening in other people's
movies or is only interesting to us pay
for maybe some mild fleeting titillation
or be as interesting or important
because it says something about our own
movie so you walk in here you're in a
bad mood of course I need by the way it
was totally minor vibrations was it it
wasn't a bad mood I was just a jeté
takus of what I just under undergone I
wouldn't have known you were agitated I
just thought slightly less bubbly than
normal but I immediately just went to oh
yeah it's probably a little annoyed that
I Adam
no come all the way out here oh yeah I
was just hoping I would get here before
you so I could get this thing set up
before you walk I got to talk to Michael
you're awesome all right well let's it's
like you know canvas your current
situation here I mean from my
perspective you have like the world's
greatest side hustle going on here I
mean this is unbelievable like you so
you were on the podcast before we shared
your story perhaps we can kind of
revisit that in a nutshell too so we can
contextualize what we're going to talk
about but while you're you know managing
this incredibly I don't know what the
word would be high-pressure
career that you're in of hosting Good
Morning America on the weekends and
doing Nightline at the same time you
have this thing going on that for
anybody else would would be an entire
career you've written multiple books on
meditation you've got the 10 percent
happier app you've went on this crazy
bus tour and you've become this like the
public face of mainstream meditation for
America or the world in this kind of
public health advocacy context like
that's a lot you have going on right now
well thank you for saying that it is a
lot I think I would say the biggest
problem right in my life right now is
time management you know I just don't
have enough time because I also have a
family three-year-old son and wife who
actually came with me to LA so we could
have we live in New York City so she
came with me just so hey we could escape
the three-year-old and right we can have
some time yeah she's had to get like a
spa right now or so that's good I
enjoyed your podcast with her oh yes I
put her on my podcast you had like some
weird trepidation about doing that but I
thought it was amazing yeah I had weird
trepidation about it because she knows
me I think she really knows me there's
no she actually knows the the the when
the mask is off I don't we're actually I
don't wear too much of a mask but she
knows what I'm like at home yeah for
real you're very self-effacing yeah and
you're in your writing and in your
presentation on the podcast so
you know and that's part of you know
that's part of your accessibility and
relatability and charm so it was
interesting to me that that seemed to
you know sort of alarm you on some level
yeah I mean I couldn't I can't control
my wife right so it's like I'm not and I
would nor what I want to but but you
know when I make self effacing facing
jokes on a podcast or in a book it's I'm
controlling it my wife's there she can
say whatever the hell she wants and she
knows everything so that was just a
little exotic right away with anything
no but it was hilarious and she
definitely gave me all the [ __ ] that I
deserve to to have been given right and
she's a very important and interesting
case study in the context of this new
book you know meditation for fidgety
skeptics because she herself despite
being your partner was not sold or at
least not on board on a practice level
with this whole thing that you're all
about these days now she asked in the
book lab whether maybe maybe I heard
myself by frequently asking her whether
what it's like to be married to your
spiritual leader the irony is she's the
one who actually got me started on
meditation she gave me a book by dr.
mark Epstein called going to pieces
without falling apart and I read that
book and realized that I had up until
that time I'd been reading a lot of sort
of Eckhart Tolle self-help stuff and I
thought was very interesting because it
talked a lot about totally I think quite
brilliantly describes our ego the voice
in our head the sort of background
static of Perpetual discontent as he
describes it but I've also heard Eckhart
Tolle and my view accurately described
as correct but not useful so he
describes our situation well but doesn't
actually give you much to do about it
and when I read Epstein's book given to
me by my wife I realized oh yeah there
is something too bad it's called
meditation and so I started meditating
as a consequence of that and then wrote
I've written a couple books about it and
God has lived with me through this
period of time she likes the meditation
in that it's made me less of an [ __ ]
than I used to be and I definitely
had I retained the capacity to be a
schmuck and have no question about it
but I was much worse way back when and
at a time when she knew me but she never
adopted herself for a whole complex
bully Abbes of reasons including you
know her schedule and her sort of
somewhat some she had a resistance to
self-care which she viewed as a bit of
self indulgent and then living with me
I'm like a wagging finger personified
even though I never I I don't lecture
her about it I did a little bit at the
beginning but I learned not to
she just had a real resistance to it and
over the course just to like
differentiate herself like she's just
not gonna get on board just didn't want
to do something that she knew I wanted
her to do marriage yeah absolutely I do
the same type of thing I get it I know
judgment I don't actually have any the
only reason I wanted her to meditate was
she has an incredibly stressful job
she's a physician but she right now
she's taking some time off but she's a
highly trained highly specialized
physician and we have a young child and
before that we had a fertility crisis
and she had breast cancer last year
so it's been she's had a tough run and I
thought this would be very useful for
her but I knew that if I said anything
she wasn't gonna do it so Jeff Warren my
co-author on the book who's this
brilliant meditation teacher he sat down
with her and he was really able to
unlock it for her and in a way that she
now does meditate and what was it
specifically that he did that unlocked
it for her a couple of things first was
he identified something that she
identified and something that I had not
seen in myself which is that my practice
my meditation practice I'm as it turns
out I learned in writing of this book
that I'm a huge hypocrite I'm always
telling people you have take it easy
don't worry about it when you get
distracted when you're meditating it
doesn't mean you've failed it's actually
the opposite you succeeded but in my own
practice I was actually very mean to
myself when I would get distracted and I
have a real sort of grit and
determination to sit a certain amount
every day and Bianca saw this she saw
that there was a sort of eat your
vegetables vibe to my
practice and it was not attractive to
her and so Jeff was like I see what you
see about dance practice get rid of that
what I think you ought to do is have a
gloriously self-indulgent practice that
at the end of the day when you put your
son to sleep and you come out I want you
to put on some reality TV turn the
volume down low sprawl out on the ground
and just notice how good it feels to lie
down tune into the physical sensations
and when you get distracted start again
and again and again he called the
meditation he created for her taking
back lazy which is a brilliant brilliant
reframing the other thing he pointed out
is that she had she often is the one she
pretty much always the one wants to put
the kid to bed because I work nights and
early morning so Bulls never awake or
available and he's really hard to get
down so she can often spend 90 minutes
200 20 minutes in there feeling rage he
was like just in and when you're lying
next to the kidneys and you're just
waiting for him to fall asleep did you
meditate right there it's already doing
you're there so she probably meditates
more than anybody I know because she's
marooned in this little monsters bed
with him and she too has co-opted that
time and turned it into meditation it's
interesting that the people that go out
of their way to make their life about
caretaking are the ones that struggle
the most with taking care of themselves
is like being a doctor and a mother that
idea that that you know you got to put
the oxygen mask on yourself before she
before you put it on the kid is so
non-intuitive and challenging for for
people like that to literally because it
feels indulgent I suppose yeah we have a
whole chapter in the book about this
bianca being primary case study blue
also spent some times some social
workers who help kids with developmental
delays in new mexico and their problem
as well
was I this is self-indulgent you know if
the five minutes I spend on meditation
I'm thinking well I could be with my
husband I could be with my son I should
be cleaning I should be doing any number
of things and it's just what you said if
you if you care truly about taking care
of other people you can't do so
effectively if you don't take care of
yourself
right but that there's that guilt yeah
even shame absolutely some people that
crops up that prevents people from from
doing that you know I think that the key
for somebody like me who's in the
position of trying to help these folks
is to acknowledge and validate those
feelings I get it I see the logic behind
your rationale but it's useful in a sort
of non-judgmental way to help help folks
see that actually under close
examination the logic doesn't hold up
right I see you as like this perfect
cipher for the average human being who
kind of knows what meditation is sort of
you know tiptoeing around the outer
edges of it but is intimidated or you
know not so keen on all of the lingo you
know language we can talk about the
importance of language if you want and
here you are this person who is like I
said earlier like you know very
relatable who speaks the same language
as the human being speaks and is able to
translate these principles through
storytelling and through science to make
these kind of very esoteric ideas
meaningful in a very practical way for
people and that's like kind of like
where you're like this wedge in between
east and west where you could take what
you know the Buddha said or Joseph
Goldstein says and translate it so the
bond trader on Wall Street or the soccer
mom in Topeka gets it I uh I really
appreciate you saying that I mean I I
kind of think of myself as a gateway
drug you know I don't know I'm not a
meditation teacher and there are great
meditation books that already existed
well my only innovation was to add the
word [ __ ] a lot you know and
and and to and to tell very embarrassing
stories and and and to tell stories at
all to really turn this to use the
skills that I had been that I had
acquired in the course of being a TV
journalist to to turn it on this on on
this practice and this tradition of
Buddhism I sometimes feel like I had
this image I was on a meditation retreat
with Joseph Goldstein my teacher couple
weeks ago and this image like I'm
standing in his vast treasury of
unbelievable material you know
unbelievable journalistic and authorial
material content and I'm like just
taking it taking stuff from Buddhism
taking stuff from meditation teachers
and I'm like is somebody gonna arrest me
I get to just take all this stuff but I
did I'm just the right person at the
right time I think maybe that I I had
all this training as a storyteller I
ended up stumbling upon meditation and
now I I can just write about it as much
as I want there's an endless supply of
things to talk about I have in my head
five more books that I want to write I
just don't have the time to do them all
right now but I would I would love to
write well I want to dig into this a
little bit more deeply but but maybe you
can give us like the twenty second recap
of how you got to this place so I had a
panic attack on the national television
viewable by anybody who wants on YouTube
how many how many views does that the
sub video millions and millions of views
yes I actually don't think it's that bad
I mean I can see like now that I know
this story when I watch it I can feel
your pain but if I just stumbled if I
just happen to have been watching it at
the time I don't know that I would have
keyed in on what exactly was how that's
right that's why my career didn't end
that morning so I get one of two
responses to the video most people see
it and they say just what you just said
you know not awesome but it's not that
bad anybody however who's had even a
taste of panic it looks that video their
posture it's like a trigger absolutely
so I happen to have handled it quite
well
I think either because I'm a sociopath
or
cuz I had the luxury of being able to
toss it back to my co-anchors if I was I
was on the air it was at seven o'clock
in the morning in 2004 and I was
supposed to read six stories off of the
teleprompter six quick stories my job
was that damn Good Morning America my
job was to be the newsreader
which they actually don't really do
anymore on morning television but these
do have people who came on at the top of
the hour and just quickly read the
headlines and as soon as I started
speaking I was overtaken by this big
bolt of fear I couldn't my heart was
racing my mind was racing my palms were
sweating my mouth dried up and most
importantly my lungs seized up I just
couldn't talk so I had to quit in the
middle and I could toss it back to the
main anchors which if I couldn't have
done that panic attack would have looked
much more from I would have ripped the
mic off and run away
more embarrassing than the panic attack
was the back story so I had spent a lot
of time as a young ambitious idealistic
reporter in war zones Iraq Afghanistan
Israel West Bank
etc etc and I came home from a lot of
these experience after having had a lot
of these experiences and I got depressed
and I very unwisely self medicated with
cocaine and ecstasy and even though I
wasn't doing drugs all the time and
definitely not when I was working it was
enough according to the doctor I
consulted after the panic attack was
enough to artificially raise the level
of adrenaline in my brain and make me
more likely to have a panic attack
and so that kind of sent me off on a
long windy weird journey that ultimately
sever the years later landed me on
meditation and the rest is and the rest
is history and now you know you're
traveling around the country in buses
but importantly not in a proselytizing
way but in a way of just trying to I
mean evangelizing the wrong word but but
it's like the wrong word being a living
example of the benefits of you know this
ancient you know way of approaching life
the gospel I think the gospel literally
means the good news and that is
basically when I'm good news the good
news if whittled down to it
is that the mind is trainable that all
the things we care the most about that
we want the most inner peace to use a
cliche term but let's just say happiness
calm compassion focus gratitude these
are skilled these are not factory
settings that you can't change these are
skills that you can practice that you
can generate you can take responsibility
for just the way you can work on your
body and the gym as you do and that is
good news and so my my whole mission on
life in life aside from I guess I have
three main missions want us to be a
journalist the second is to be a daddy
and and husband and the third is to tell
people this right and I'm just trying to
come up with creative ways to help you
play you can if there are things about
yourself that you don't like you can't
magically make them go away like I'm
still shorter than I want to be etcetera
etcetera but you can train equanimity
you can train kindness generosity these
are these are in Crescent incredible
thing to know and so to me yeah that's a
kind of evangelism but importantly to
amplify the point you were trying to
make before that I probably cut you off
in the middle of is that I don't wag my
finger for real look if you're not
interested in meditation I'm not gonna
talk to you about it I only talk to
people about meditation who like you
gave me a microphone so I'll talk but
like for years I didn't talk to my wife
about it because I knew she didn't to
hear it right what's interesting about
what you just said is this idea of news
good or otherwise that it's news in the
Western world this idea that we can
train the mind that we can there are
things that we can do that we can
practice that can amplify our equanimity
that can make us more focus that can you
know reduce the stress in our lives and
and and set us on a trajectory towards
achieving all those things that that we
spend so much time and effort on in
other areas of our life to achieve which
is happiness fulfillment 10-man you know
living purposefully all of these things
right and we do spend an unbelievable
amount of time in the gym or you know at
our job or doing whatever we're doing
without any regard whatsoever for how
this thing you know that's sitting on
top of our shoulders actually functions
we spent so much time our stock
portfolios our cars our bodies our
interior design our resumes all of which
are important I'm not I'm I spend time
on those things but it's important to
spend time as well on the one filter
through which you experience everything
and that's your mind and I think this is
news people don't know this I didn't
know this I mean I I did not know that
any of this was possible I didn't even
know the I was not even truly aware of
the thunderously obvious fact that we
have minds and our thinking and you know
I mean yes if you had asked me on the
street you have a mind and you are you
thinking yeah I would have said yes but
I I wasn't aware of the intensity of the
non-stop conversation we are having with
ourselves all the time this just chaotic
stew of urges and impulses and desires
that is your inner life and when you
don't see it clearly it owns you and
that's all that meditation is it's a
systematic waking waking up to this
reality so that you can surf it rather
than be drawer you know drowned by it
mhm and as much as it is news here I
mean this goes back you know hundreds
thousands of years in the East like
millennia news you know you know a large
part of the world were were that we're
late to the party yes and what's
interesting is that science has now sort
of caught up to this trend to verify it
in a way that legitimizes it to the
rational you know logical way that we as
Westerners kind of perceive the world I
mean that's what allowed me to get over
the hump because I was coming to the
extent that I had ever even thought
about meditation I thought it was
ridiculous I mean you know I often joke
that I thought it was you know for
people who live in a yard and are really
into Enya and Cat Stevens and you know
live in a spend time on a Himalayan
mountain top in the loincloth I mean
just you know the all the cliches but it
was the science that changed my mind my
wife's in scientists both my parents are
scientists I was not good enough at math
too
do science but I carries a lot of weight
with me when I saw the science that
suggests that it can lower your blood
pressure boost your immune system
literally rewire key parts of your brain
then I thought okay this makes sense and
importantly for me as somebody who
struggle with anxiety and depression as
well as panic and substance abuse the
this the science around anxiety and
depression is actually the strongest and
I just you know in testing it in the
laboratory of my own mind it became very
obvious that when you can have some
distance from your repetitive grim
thought patterns your neurotic programs
your inter neurotic programs then then
they don't control you as much and
that's what depression anxiety consists
of maybe we can go in a little bit more
deeply on on what the science actually
does say and doesn't say so one thing to
say about the science first is that it
has been it continues to be regrettably
hyped so I think people overstate what
meditation can do and they latch onto
every hot new study and and then there's
some breathless headline about our
meditation can you know make you dunk on
a regulation hoop or whatever it's just
not that that is not the case I think
it's important to point out that the
that the studies that the research is in
it's early stages and that well we can't
say much definitively what we can say is
it strongly suggests the research
strongly suggests that meditation can
confer a number of really attractive
benefits from as I said before lower
your blood pressure boosting your immune
system it's been shown to help with
grades in school behavior in school it's
been shown to help with anxiety
depression
age-related cognitive decline ADHD and
the neuroscience is really the most
exciting stuff that I'll just give you
one study that was done at Harvard in
2010 or 11 they took people who had
never meditated before just civilians
and they scanned their brains to get a
baseline reading of what their brains
look like and then for eight weeks they
had them do a little bit of meditation
every day at the end they scanned their
brains again and what they found is in
the area of the brain associated with
stress
the gray matter literally shrink and in
the area of the brain associated with
self-awareness and also compassion the
gray matter group that is just really
compelling and it's also shown to have a
salutary effect on the areas of the
brain associated with attention
regulation and another one last thing
I'll say about this is there's a
connected there a series of regions of
the brain known as the default mode
Network these are the areas of the brain
that fire when we're in our default mode
which is thinking about ourselves
thinking about the past thinking about
the future just kind of ruminating
that's just the that's our resting state
as humans meditators while meditating
that area of the brain the activity goes
way down and importantly for long-term
meditators
it goes way down even when you're not
meditating mm-hmm that's that's pretty
compelling and amazing yeah yes I feel
like we're in a very tenuous interesting
time I mean there's a lot going on right
now you know we're in unchartered waters
politically and particularly with
respect to emerging technology there is
a war for our time and attention afoot
and and maybe there always has been but
with the advent of all of these devices
that are vying for you know vying for
our eyeballs I feel like you know we we
have to be we almost have to be
practicing some form of meditation to
avoid the compulsion that we all are
faced with with just pulling the phone
out of our pocket every day and looking
at it like I don't know about you but I
can go down the rabbit like I'll be
scrolling through Instagram and I'll be
like I can't stop scrolling what is
roughly what is wrong with me and that
and I realize like well you know a lot
of time and attention and millions of
dollars were put into this app to
achieve precisely this result so that
they're achieving with me and I have to
go above and beyond and exercise like
you know a lot of mindfulness and
restraint
to like create rules around these things
and avoid them so that I can actually
move forward in my life yeah in other
words we're in a period where boredom
need not exist ever again yeah we are so
over stimulated and there's a lot of
amazing things about that but you know
we're in many respects we're prisoners
right and so if you start to think of it
in that context what are the tools to
unlock us from this prison that we've
that we've all volunteered for I had
interviewed recently a very interesting
person named Anu she's M roadie who she
hosts a podcast called note to self and
it's all about sort of our relationship
to technology and she said and I'm
probably gonna mangle the quote but that
were in an essence conducting a huge
science experiment global science
experiment about our attention within
our relationship to these to these
devices because we're just we don't know
what it does to us we know some things
but we just don't really know what the
long-term effects are of having this a
supercomputer in your pocket and just
being glued to it all the time my view
and I'm open to change my my view right
now is that you know these are
incredible tools and they're so useful
and so delightful on so many different
levels but it's very important to try to
create a healthy relationship to them so
I'm not I mean I before we started
rolling here I was talking about how I
went out and splurged on the iPhone 10 i
mean i-i I don't I'm not anti tech but I
am anti unhappiness and I find that
having a mindfulness practice which
essentially just boosts your
self-awareness right through having
increased self-awareness because of
meditation I noticed more quickly when
like I'm just I'm doing this because I'm
bored I'm doing this because I'm lonely
I'm doing this I'm drowning in Twitter
and I'm my stomach is roiling and my
head is pounding because I'm upset about
some political development step away man
and that has really helped me so it's
not to say that I never
use technology it's just that my
relationship to it has become more
healthy and then the other thing I'd say
is that I love that there's this
proliferation of meditation apps out
there because it it's like co-opting the
engine of our distraction and turning
your phone into something that teaches
you how to be mindful I think there's a
reason why these companies are doing so
well yeah it is it's super interesting
and and I can kind of contextualize it
or analogize it to - you know recovery
from substance abuse because I see my
own denial mechanism creep up like oh
well yeah I'm I'm on Twitter while I'm
waiting in this line because you know my
career is tied to social media and I
need to know what's going on and I it's
like it's [ __ ] you know I don't need
to be doing that like but to be able to
catch myself in that argument and have
enough self-awareness to say that's just
a lie that I'm telling myself to to
validate this behavior that I know you
know deep down it's not in my best
interest it's just seeing it is a huge
victory but I can always go on the ten
percent happy happier app instead right
I mean it's really cool like I think
it's you did a really great job thank
you and you know I I was on headspace
for quite some time and I know Andy and
I think they've done an amazing job
they're pioneers yeah incredible right
incredible and what you've done I was
always you know curious before you
launched your app like well what's he
gonna do that that they're not doing or
how do you differentiate and I think
you've done an amazing job of creating
something unique and different that also
you know serves the same ultimate goal
with the video and the various different
teachers and and you know it's really
and it's it's fun you know it's not it
goes to that thing that you said earlier
like this transition that you went
through from that period of time when
you wrote 10% happier when you were
looking at meditation like your
vegetables or just something that you
have to like you got to do it you got to
like get through it or whatever just
something that you look forward to
that's enjoyable it's funny because well
first of all thank you for saying all
that because the app has become really
just you made your focus for me is just
my baby and
and I had no prior experience in
business but luckily was able to through
a long series of events that you
probably don't care about find it's
amazing team and we just are having so
much fun doing this thing but you know
in terms of making it fun I come from
morning television and I often think you
know weekend Good Morning America which
is one of the shows I do it at ABC our
success in the ratings is because if we
yes we give you the news we do all the
things that you check on all the boxes
but the five of us who are on the show
we love each other we're having a great
time and it feels like a party that you
want to be at and I want the app to feel
that way that that it's not just dry
meditation instructions when you watch
the short little video clips that we
serve up all the time right before you
sit to meditate although you can just
meditate if you want but if you watch
the video clips it's fun it's super
practical it's me sitting with some
brilliant teacher or scientist and you
learn something that can actually change
the way you live but also have fun doing
it to me that is just such a no it's an
amazing experience yeah it's cool how
Jeff ends the sessions by saying you
know welcome to our meditation call yes
so we you know our little slogan is nope
nope nope and floats you know we we just
the way meditations been delivered is
either dry or twee or super like
addressing you as if you're grasshopper
you know that we're trying to avoid all
of those tropes and just stick with what
this is which is secular simple exercise
for your brain but also as soon as you
start just like you were talking about
when you're online at the supermarket
and you see you're checking Twitter and
then you're engaging in all of these
sort of crazy rationalize
rationalizations that's hilarious
when you look at your mind it's [ __ ]
hilarious because it's crazy it's
totally crazy if you can't have a sense
of humor about this you are in deep
trouble and I think that's what we're
trying to bring to this thing is it's
not that you're gonna
career neuroses it's it's that as one
great meditation teacher has said you'll
become a connoisseur of your neuroses so
that said that there don't have so much
power over you yeah and just to break it
down and make it super accessible and
simple so that anybody can follow it
yeah and to use language that people
understand I mean we kind of danced
around this earlier but you know the
importance of the importance of language
with ideas like this and you've sort of
famously said like you know meditation
is you know is in the greatest need of
like rebranding or like a new marketing
strategy because the idea that like like
I'm just envisioning two guys watching
Monday Night Football sitting next to
each other and one leaning over to the
other one and saying you know how's your
loving-kindness prophesied it's like
it's not gonna happen right and yet
these are profound practices that we can
all benefit from if we and I think guys
you know have a harder time with the
language then than women do for sure but
you know two guys watching Monday Night
Football might say you know how was your
CrossFit class sure so but this is
exercise for the mind and the brain and
there's a reason why the Chicago Cubs
meditate this reason why i novak
djokovic meditates the US Army and the
US Marines are spending tens of millions
of dollars on meditation for the troops
for a reason this is us up these are
bicep curls for your brain and and there
are lots of different practices that can
work on lots of different mental
qualities that you care about we just
need to start talking about it this way
so that it's not embarrassing to talk
about it at Monday Night Football
because those guys deserve this practice
just as much as the traditional Yogi's
who've been doing it forever deserve it
everybody deserves it this is our
birthright mindfulness is our birthright
having a mind is our birthright and so
this should be done by foster care
children this should be done by inmates
and prisons this should be done by
patients and hospitals
nobody is outside the scope you've been
doing this for a while now and and your
initiation into this was you know very
much about like trying to reframe it
and redefine it for yourself but as
somebody who's now been around the block
and has gotten to know all these amazing
teachers and is very steeped in the
Traverse traditions etc do you find
yourself at times like nothing static so
I would imagine your relationship with
this is it's certainly more profound and
different than it was when you begin but
do you find yourself kind of gravitating
a little bit towards the patchouli crowd
in a way that you weren't initially
because I'm just thinking like I
analogize this to when I adopted a vegan
diet like I was like I'm never gonna be
vegan because those guys kick hacky
sacks and have the dreadlocks and talk
about things that I'm not interested in
you know like it and now ten years later
like I kind of have become one of those
guys a little bit you know in a way that
I never would have thought not by
conscious design but by evolution I
think it's such a great question the
short answer is not really
like I'm not as offended by it as I used
to be and so I can be in the room when
people are you know talking the talk but
I still pretty offended by it I don't
like you know like with Jeff and I were
writing this book and we we did some so
we did straight-up mindfulness practices
in the book boy we also did some as you
said before loving-kindness practice
which I have a whole rap about we can
get into it but we so we did some
practices that are designed to boost
your compassion and I told them don't
use the word heart because that's just
what does that even mean it's just kind
of sappy so I still have some linguistic
peccadilloes and little rules that I
like to stick to because I think there's
a way to talk about this that makes it
less annoying but I am now way in the
tank for meditation and I regularly go
on meditation retreats and have a deep
relationship with a this amazing
meditation teacher Joseph Goldstein
who's my view perhaps the greatest
living meditation teacher and so it it's
it's in a funny place catering to
skeptics while I meditate two hours a
day
leigh-anne go on these long meditation
retreats and it is that is you put your
finger on a tricky balance for me but I
haven't really given an inch on my firm
convictions about the right and wrong
way to talk about the practices yeah as
a translator yes yes and and that that's
certainly you know that's your that's
your place that's your talent that's
your that's your role at least as you as
you see it clearly like everything you
do is is a way of translating these
ideas to so the average person that
that's my goal that is definitely my
goal is it really to out you're doing
two hours a day yeah so a couple of
years ago maybe two and a half years ago
I got it in my head so not long after
10% happier came out I just got it in my
head that I really wanted to go deeper
the logic being not that I you know
thought that I guess that the way to
describe the logic is it's demonstrably
true in my experience and based on the
science that you can train yourself to
be kinder and more mindful and more
focused at all this thing so if you can
be 10% happier what's the ceiling and
I've become very interested in what's
available at the sort of deeper end of
the pool not only sort of as a
journalist because I plan to write about
this at some point but also as a human
you know I saw so many benefits so for
example one way to think about this is
like with exercise so I okay you know I
like being fit I got to look at my
stupid face in television so I try not
to be overweight and I my wife and I
went to SoulCycle this morning and and
at work six or seven days a week I work
out you run these crazy like Ironman
things and so I would never do that but
I don't think of crazy because you do
it's just that you personally got so
interested in it that you wanted to take
it further that's kind of what I'm going
for in the meditation side although any
serious meditations like really serious
meditation person knows that I
personally am not yet a meditative
triathlete but I am making the bet my my
best attempts to move in that direction
so about two and a half years ago I had
it in my head that two hours a day was
the right number I don't know that it's
kind of it's kind of out there that to
ours is a number that a lot of dedicated
practitioners do and I heard from my
friend Sharon Salzberg an amazing thing
she had a friend who Sharon is a great
meditation teacher and she's been on the
podcast ok so your listeners who know
her that's which is amazing she is
amazing she had a friend who wanted to
do two hours but was very busy and he
came up with this rule of I can do
whenever I want wherever I want and
whatever increments I want throughout
the day and so now that's my rule I just
I wake up in the morning I don't know
when or where I'm gonna meditate or for
how long and I just fit it in where I
can and and that by the end of the day I
get to two hours on a great day I'll
Bank a little bit for the next day not a
shitty day I'll like come up short and
have to make that up the next day so
today for example I've taken a lot of
cars around LA and you know lyft in the
backseat of lift cars and I've got a lot
of time to meditate and so I'll probably
io4 to five minutes from a couple of
weeks ago I'll make it up today yeah
interesting and how long have you been
doing the two-hour experiment almost
three years Oh three years almost three
years about two and a half three years
and what is the qualitative difference
in your life between that and the more
typical you know twenty minutes a day or
twenty minutes in the morning in twenty
minutes at night I just think it's it's
taking the the benefits you get as a
beginner and ramping them up it's not
that I'm you know in some bubble of
bliss you know with like bulletproof
imperturbability or anything like that
it's just that so what are the three
benefits you get as a beginning
meditator increase calm increase focus
and less emotional reactivity
I just turned up the volume on all three
of those well the other thing I've
noticed is that my actual practice is
better this is a skill you know people
sit down to meditate and they find
immediately that they're super
distractible which often people assume
that's a failure but it's not I've just
found that actually my ability to focus
has gone up over time it's sort of more
and more interesting and pleasurable
things happen to meditation and when
unpleasant things happen I'm actually
able to be a quantum 'since a sin the
minute not all the time but it
at a much higher level than I used to be
well certainly you know the the the
proof is in the pudding in terms of like
your productive output I mean the fact
that you're you're a host on two
different television shows you're
writing books presumably you're
traveling all the time to speak and
you're doing things like podcasts you
you have your own podcast at the same
time you've got this app like you're
doing you're a dad and you're I mean
that would just blow the mind of the
average human being or create so much
anxiety that it would become an
unsustainable situation yeah I I have a
suspicion that that has to do with
meditation it's funny I've only recently
started to think that because there's a
long time where I was doing the two
hours and it was a bit of a stunt I was
thinking because I said I want to write
a book about enlightenment at some point
so I was kind of at my initial instinct
was a little crass it was like okay
let's see let's see what happens what
kind of it in AJ Jacobs kind of
absolutely yeah I actually thought of
that I maybe there's a book called a
year of living dharmically you know like
because he wrote a book called a year
living biblically right but I realized
that first of all I don't want to do it
just for a year I want it this is the
way I want to live and so my interest
isn't this isn't actually just stunt
journalism after a while I started to
realize that this is I I actually want
to be doing this level of practice if
not more and and I actually have come to
believe and I don't have any evidence to
support this but I have to come I've
come to believe what you just described
that mmm this kind of crazy workload has
become I've is enabled by the fact that
I do have this practice that gives me
the ability to stay focused when I need
to stay focused and also to not suffer
as much you know like suffering in the
Buddhist sense you know the Buddha's
describe suffering as just clinging to
things you want and pushing things away
that you don't want
lacking any equanimity in the face of
life's in next you know inevitable
vicissitudes and I think I've gotten a
little bit better it just kind of being
more supple in my dealings with reality
that isn't to say I'm perfect because I
am definitely not but I I had this
suspicion that this practice which
started as a bit of a lark is really
helping me do all the things I want to
do it's multifactorial though because I
think another part of it is just
flat-out greed not necessarily greed for
money because you know like I don't make
any money off of the I don't get paid by
the app you know we're a startup
but greed for like lust for I am I have
doing all the things I love you know I
mean I love being a journalist at ABC
News I'm so I've been there for nearly
18 years I love ABC News and such deep
relationships there so much gratitude
for the amount of experience the
experiences they've given me and just I
love the people at Nightline I work with
and we can GMA I'm just absolutely love
it all and then the writing these books
and having this company in a podcast I
can't get to hang out with people like
you this is incredible opportunity and
then having a family you know we had a
huge as I mentioned before infertility
struggle and so I just do not take for
granted
my three-year-old even when he's pooping
on me so all of this is just so there's
a lizard greed just trying to wring out
of life everything I can and also
navigating your wife's breast cancer
that was brutal man she's okay now
alright she's cured ah she's great and
but look I mean I have to state the
blazingly obvious she was a thousand
times worse for her than it was for me
with a lot of very painful surgeries and
a lot of fear and but I will say that
that practice particularly the
before-mentioned loving-kindness
practices that we haven't yet fully
excavated but maybe we will really made
a difference you know I'm squeamish I'm
selfish I am NOT by nature nurturing and
having a baby around the house and a
wife who is as sick as she was big
challenge for me and you know I found it
actually in the end it really was I
heard Bianca say recently that it was
the best thing that ever happened to her
getting sick that way and I would say
was also the best thing that happened to
our relationship that we just I really
had to she's always been the caretaker
she's a doctor she's actually naturally
very very compassionate and we were but
yin and yang in that way I'm a little
more sort of aloof and I had to you know
really step up and I found that I I
don't want to say enjoyed it but I found
a lot of meaning in engaging in that way
and her gratitude stems from being able
to reprioritize yeah her life yes as she
says she was just kind of hurdling along
in this high-powered medical career and
parenting and a husband who was just
non-stop and the breast cancer really
made her stop and take stock and she's
in the middle of this process of taking
stock but she is for the first time
really taking care of herself she's
gotten really into SoulCycle that I
mentioned we went to souls like oh
there's more happy interested you hear
your thoughts on your candid thoughts on
Souls like oh but now it's look anything
that gets anybody excited about being
active yeah so I was actually very down
and so it's likely because I used to do
other forms of spin and I thought were
much harder then I realised actually I
was doing so slightly wrong I was that I
wasn't actually rhythm writing that
other forms of soul cycle arts and
others forms of spin or like go this
fast at this time for this many second
souls like I was actually just about
writing to the rhythm with enough
resistance so that you kill yourself
that way and so I took me awhile to
figure it out and so we do that together
we have a great to watch her take care
of herself after years of not really
taking care of herself as you're
meditating and exercising in these ways
so I think it's been really good for her
and good for us that's amazing I want to
get back to you know this this sort of
contentment that you were expressing you
know that you get to do all these things
and you have this very big life you know
it's it's almost intimidating to like
talk about all these different things
because it is it is like for the average
person that would be anxiety producing
how are you gonna
and like but just so you do okay like
yeah you're okay you're a human being
yeah glad to hear that
but I think it begs a question of
happiness itself like you know the first
book memoir sort of you know an argument
in favor of meditation dressed up as a
memoir through storytelling you know you
make this compelling argument about the
benefits of meditation the title is 10%
happier like what is happiness and and
how do you think about happiness in
terms of you know a way of living or how
does that kind of line up against other
ideas comparable ideas like contentment
fulfilment living purposefully living
mindfully I have a whole rap on this
this or the the the the those other
words are more specific and truly more
meaningful happiness is the reason why I
chose happiness or happier is because
that's the word we use more frequently
but it actually doesn't mean much and in
fact if you look I think I might have
said this in my first book that the very
roots of the word linguistically adamah
etymologically reflect our cultural
ambivalence about the subject hap h8p is
the same it's like haphazard hapless it
means luck so happiness is like
something you luck into when in fact as
discussed before in Tesla for it's it's
really interesting so when in fact
happiness is a skill I spent a lot of
time asking happiness experts like
meditation gurus you know how do you
define happiness and nobody ever gave me
a satisfying answer until dr. mark
Epstein who I talked about before who
wrote the book that really got me
interested in this entry point yeah da
mark and I were having dinner and I
asked him how do you define happiness
and he said something to me that was not
meaningful at the time but I've come to
believe that it is the smartest thing I
have heard about happiness
he said more of the good stuff and less
of the bad okay what does that mean I've
come to think about it in kind of
geometric terms
I'm terrible at math but if you think
about psychologists have this theory
called the set point theory so if you
think about a graph it has an x-axis and
a y-axis the x-axis runs horizontally so
the set point theory is the x-axis is so
kind of like you we all have a happiness
set point so good things can happen and
we you know our happiness level goes up
and then we tend to revert back to our
set point the x-axis the sort of
straight line and then bad things happen
to us and then our happiness goes below
the set point eventually we were kind of
revert to it that this is there's a
theory about the way we are as humans
that we have this kind of happiness set
point in my experience that that sounds
right but that what happens with
meditation is that the top end of that
graph the way you are when good things
happen gets taller and more sustained
because you are more you're enjoying in
a more fulsome manner the for lack of
less cheesy word blessings in your life
and you're not so busy running rushing
off to see what the next hit of dopamine
might write might be so that's the top
of the graph and then the bottom of the
graph is when bad things happen to you
and I think through the meditation it's
like I become the bottom half becomes
shallower that you're spending less time
in useless rumination and you're kind of
recovering more quickly and then
meanwhile I think the setpoint itself
moves up and to me that's how I think
about happiness is how are you
navigating life's ups and downs and are
you getting the most out of the ups and
are you maximally resilient in the face
of the doubt yeah I've heard Sam Harris
your friend talk about the the kind of
half-life of negative emotions yes
brilliant used right yeah so you know
whether you have this yeah of course
that's I got that for you well you're
you're angry or you're resentful or
you're you're looping in your mind some
you know insanity that the half-life is
much shorter it will dissipate and go
away it's among Sam is a valued friend
of mine and he has said many brilliant
things that I steal that is one of them
he talks about that one of the benefits
of men
having to do with the half-life of anger
that you know you we still are going to
experience difficult emotions unless
your enlightenment if you even believe
in that I don't know if I believe in it
you got it right this other book I I'm
gonna write this a pursuit of unless we
are still going to experience negative
emotions the mystery of consciousness is
we don't know where our thoughts and
feelings come from that come out of a
void
you can't which is liberating to know
because there's no point holding
yourself responsible you did this today
you you got angry at being angry for
forgetting your pod your audio equipment
at home and started telling yourself a
whole story
which you caught yourself doing but you
did do it anyway and we all do this we
have a feeling you know impatience with
our child impatience with our spouse
whatever and we tend to get into these
knots of self laceration around I'm this
kind of person as a consequence of
having just had this feeling we didn't
invite the feeling it just came out of a
void we don't know where it came from
you can't hold yourself responsible for
what you feel but you can hold yourself
responsible for how you deal with it and
so when anger ambushes you for me I deal
with a lot of anger if I can see it if I
have an inner meteorologist that can
tell me when the storm is brewing is
about to hit landfall make landfall then
it I may either let it pass and not be
taken over by it or I may get a few
miles down the road with it you know a
couple minutes of doing something stupid
but then I catch myself the the amount
of damage as sam says that you can do in
two minutes of anger as opposed to an
hour of anger is incalculable and that
is the fruit of meditation which is why
I was so jazzed about the story you told
at the top of this podcast because
because it epitomizes what the value of
his practice is the beginning part of
that for me is understanding that there
is a distinction between the thinking
mind and
you know your I don't know what you
would want to call it your higher
consciousness your awareness having
awareness of the thinking mind being the
observer of the thinking mind and that
kind of like duality right that these
are actually different things yes which
is kind of a mind blood I mean even go
down the rabbit hole on that forever
it's kind of a mind-blowing thing and it
begs the question of you know what is
consciousness
what is our minds and you know what is
actually going on here like how do you
think about that kind of stuff I mean
you just put your finger on perhaps the
most interesting question facing mankind
you know this is the fundamental mystery
what is consciousness we know that we
know stuff those you know what it feels
like if you're driving right now you
know that you're the feeling of your
hands on the wheel you know that you're
thinking but what knows it right try to
find the little rich roll in your head
you rich or whoever's listening try to
close your eyes but don't close your
eyes if you're driving and try to find
you that you won't we don't know what
knows it does that mean it doesn't exist
I think the argument that gets made in
this where it gets into the deep end and
I'm in some ways sort of insufficiently
qualified to talk about it so anybody
who is qualified and here to be talking
about it I apologize in advance but I
think what the Buddhists would say is
that this gets into the illusion of the
self that we which is the primordial lie
we are telling ourselves we think there
is some core rich you know some core Dan
and us on all of our negative emotions
that is the wellspring of all of our
negative emotions because we have greed
to gratify the inner rich we have hatred
to defend our whatever we have we have
you know and then confusion about
reality as a consequence of embracing
this lie but the simplest way to think
about this is there is a difference
between your thoughts and
your awareness of your thoughts so the
thoughts or emotions or anything you're
aware of or like actors walking onto the
stage right they pass through our clouds
going through the sky your awareness
your consciousness you just is the stage
or it is the sky if you want to whatever
analogy wanted to use so we don't know
what's sky is in this analogy here we
don't know exactly what the stage is and
you can get into lots of discussions
about what it is but for just your
rank-and-file meditator if that doesn't
really matter the only interesting thing
to the most practical thing to be aware
of is that there is a difference between
your raw bear awareness of things like
when you're just feeling the sensations
of your butt on the chair that is just
playing old awareness then there's
thinking about the feelings of your butt
in the chair of me I got to do more
exercising my butt is too big those are
just thoughts that's a different thing
and well none of these are things
actually that's just an interesting idea
but the more that you self identify your
awareness with the actors on that stage
the more that you will suffer absolutely
and the more that you can to the extent
that you can transcend that
self-identification and and and kind of
step into a more expansive understanding
of oneness the more you can free
yourself from the chains of of that
cycle of suffering yeah I think it's
just like to me it's like interrogating
the mystery a little bit if you can do
this little exercise which is a Buddhist
exercise that Tibetan exercise you know
close your eyes and hear whatever sounds
were there you know there's all sorts of
sounds my voice may be the little tape
hiss whatever and then ask yourself what
is hearing this and you won't find it
but in the not finding as the Buddhists
say there is a kind of liberation
because you're not you're seeing how
you're seeing the mystery the
fundamental mystery of your own identity
and of our existence and that can dis
identify disentangle you from all of the
suffering that we're creating of
being so entangled with our thoughts and
and our stories and all that stuff it's
not magic and it's not permanent and
unless again you're enlightened but it
can in just moment after moment does is
cut theory in meditation circles of
short moments many times that if you
just kind of are touching this mystery
over and over and over again it has the
net effect of making you lighter and and
pushing you closer toward enlightenment
whether you believe that something or
not as beautiful as that sentiment is
the prospect of really confronting that
in yourself is terrifying because how's
it we're sort of raised and taught to to
you know identify with these stories
that we tell ourselves about who we are
I am this for I am dan I am a journalist
I am rich I am whatever right and we we
craft these narratives around identity
that we delude ourselves are real and so
to kind of engage with what you were
just talking about is to kind of
dismantle that yeah but in a certain way
yeah that's right but there are two way
there to the Buddhists talk about this
in a way that actually is comforting
which is to there are kind of two levels
to life two levels to reality there's
the relative truth you know you still
are rich you you know on the day to day
basis you know even if rich doesn't
exist on some deep level you still use
left put your pants on in the morning
and you still need your podcast
equipment if you want to do a podcast
and that that is just the truth on a
sort of relative on one on the on the
level in which most of us operate on
which most of us operate most of the
time but there is a deeper truth which
they often call ultimate truth which is
kind of it can be roughly analogized to
quantum physics so like this table that
you and I are in doing an interview on
he is a table but at the deepest level
it's a bunch of spinning atoms and it
space and so the same is true with the
self and so you don't need to get deep
you don't need to get too wrapped up in
this it's just it's a sec it's a it's a
useful thing to think of in so much as
it can help you not get so wrapped up in
your own stories well I think this is a
good kind of place to launch into
talking a little bit about the obstacles
that people have to embracing to
embracing meditation to begin with which
is really the heart and soul of this new
book meditation for fidgety skeptics
because as I understand it like you know
it's gonna ask you like you know why I
write this book but you know I already
know the answer to that which is that
you were under the impression that
writing the first book would state this
case for meditation then I overall would
read it and then adopt these practices
and live happier lives and you were sort
of surprised that that was not the
immediate despite this being this book
was a huge success right like that was
not the reaction that you it was not the
reaction I got I mean I first of all I
didn't think any was gonna read it I was
like my view was I'm like a b-level
Network newsman writing about something
at the time it was pretty niche you know
meditation was no it was had some
cultural capital but it wasn't was a
super hot as hot as it is now so I just
didn't think anybody's gonna read it yes
in and up becoming pretty successful
which was delightful and amazing
probably the most one of the most
consequential professional developments
of my life and so gratifying but it was
humbling to see that it didn't have the
effect because you know I actually own
10% happier I didn't set out to write a
memoir I initially was gonna write a
how-to book but then the memoir parts of
it were the only parts that anybody that
was reading it liked I mean it's the
it's the story that allows people to
emotionally connect yet with you so that
they can hear the other part right but I
didn't
I didn't I mean I only put some like a
few pages of how-to stuff away at the
back of the book uh-huh and I got a very
interesting phone call from a friend of
mine
Daniel Goldman who he wrote a seminal
book called emotional intelligence and
he's a big meditator and he called me up
it was like this is great it's so cool
that you're getting so people excited
about meditation but you you do have
some responsibility to actually teach
them how to do the thing and that was a
big kind of a that set me on my heels
and and I had to really think about what
could work what should I do
so the first thing I did was I ended up
co-founding this company called 10%
happier we have this meditation app that
we've discussed and it's been incredible
incredibly fun to do this and I've also
learned a lot and one of the things I
learned as being part of this company is
while being part of this company is is
that there's this rich pageant of
neuroses that stop people from
meditating and or embracing any healthy
habit and so that is why I wanted to
write this book and but I didn't want to
write a dry meditation manual because I
didn't think anybody would read that so
I decided to do it as a story so I
rented this big orange tour bus
previously occupied by Parliament
Funkadelic and we went 18 states in 11
days me and Jeff Warren who's this
meditation teacher from Toronto and and
we met all of these different people at
you know all these different stops cops
politicians celebrities social workers
and you know you use them as a case
studies for each of the eight main
obstacles we identified so the book is
trying to do three things at once it's
like a fun story of this gonzo road trip
it also is a systematic classification
of all the obstacles to medicate and
meditation and then answers about how to
surmount them and it's a how-to book
halfway through the writing the book
when I was tearing my hair out I was
like oh yeah so there's a reason why
nobody's written a book like this before
this is fun
but what's great about it is that it is
a fun story because it's a it's a it's
like a bromance road trip like you and
Jeff hit it off you guys develop this
amazing relationship and and you embark
on this adventure together and you know
hilarity ensues yeah along the way we
learn lessons you learn how to meditate
and you kind of are able to quantify all
of these reasons or these barriers that
people throw up that's preventing them
from accessing this tool that has been
so transformational in your own life and
it begins before you even go on the road
with your own co-workers and and staff
which I thought was really like
instructive and hilarious to see like
these people that you work with and
you've had this you know epiphany in
your life and yet they're like they're
on a totally different page with this
stuff like co-anchors at Good Morning
America my weekend so we have this
little you know tight-knit group that we
can GMA because we're the sort of
weekenders you know not not the a-team
and but we really love each other and we
have you know we're up early together on
the weekend so we just got very lucky
that we they the bosses put together a
bunch of people will really have close
relationships and they make fun of me
for being the meditation guy all the
time but they all have interest in it
but aren't doing it so I brought in Jeff
what I call the meditation MacGyver to
see if he could help them get over the
hump and we had this hilarious session
where these people who just never shut
up their jobs require them to never shut
up like dead air is the is the the thing
we all fear you know trying to get them
to sit quietly and meditate was a real
challenge and one of them Paula Faris
who is my my work wife she's my
co-anchor on the show the coho were the
two main hosts of the show
she literally she did something I've
never seen anybody do before she turned
the meditation the actual guided
meditation into a call in response she
was interrupting Jeff and asking him
questions like a lot of questions they
were good questions and Paula's are very
very smart so it was they were useful
questions but I'd never seen anybody
sort of break protocol in this way and
it was interesting because you know
after Ezra partly as a consequence of
this session you know Paula is now a
pretty regular meditator that's really
cool and she had a different idea for
the title of this book yes she wanted to
call it ten percent less of a douchebag
or 10 percent happier but still a
douchebag she refers to herself as the
little sister dad never wanted
uh-huh but God anyway yeah she likes to
torture me but how brilliant is it that
like you have you know you have this
whole other life in this meditation
world but you have this you have this
platform where you go on national TV and
like talk about it it's kind of amazing
it's such is such a friend of mine wrote
me a note the other day saying you know
congrat the book seems to be doing well
congratulations I was like dude I have a
minor advantage which is that the one of
the largest media companies on earth
he's like this full throated back erm
you know my bosses at ABC have been just
like irrationally supportive they're
just like you want to start a company
great you want to do a podcast great you
want to write more books awesome I'll
help you promote them they're just
incredible I mean they're absolutely
because I could have just shut it down
and say oh so we need your full
attention on what we hired you to do I
mean part of the deal is they know that
I work seven days a week and I'm so
super committed to ABC and so I mean I
have to pull up I have to do my side of
the bargain but you know they have been
amazing and I think oh I think there are
a lot of reasons for it
you know just the depths of the
relationships that we that I have at the
company the fact that my boss has
happened to be just very cool and also
that this is a healthy message to be
putting out there and I think it's just
good for everyone to be promoting it I
mean it'd be different if I don't know
if I was writing like how to pick up
ladies or something you know you know
something right it's a blessing service
yeah it behooves ABC to recognize that
and embrace it I think so
I think so and you know like there are a
lot of people at ABC or into meditation
of George Stephanopoulos Robin Roberts
Diane Sawyer there are a lot of people
there who are on board and I think that
has helped
do you have like secret behind the
velvet rope like top-level ABC like
executive washroom meditation especial
no but I did do a private thing with the
staff of Nightline the other day because
and it was so interesting because we
have a very tight-knit staff very
heavily heavily female and they're all
like Robocop's in in the sense that that
you know like a Robocop was like a cop
invented a lab who could do everything
perfectly well these people these women
mostly women although some men - they
can shoot the stories they can produce
the stories that can write the stories
they can do it all and they're there's
an enormous amount of stress in what
they do and to sit and talk to them
about the stress and how they feel the
stress actually this is another thing we
tackle in the book they feel like the
stress is necessary to do the job that
right that if they don't have the stress
they'll lose their edge and it was
really interesting to talk to them about
how actually you know there are ways to
manage the stress so that you don't wear
down your resiliency and energy so that
was a really useful private session with
my team it was nice
yeah I think I think that is a really is
a big one with a lot of people certainly
a big one with me and the way you kind
of break the book down it's it's divided
into sections that address each one of
these objections and we don't have time
to go through all of them but I think
that's one of the ones that that is is
one worthy of exploring a little bit
because as somebody who's ambitious
who's you know in certain respects you
know has alpha tendencies I have
developed this idea that myself will and
my workaholism and my ability to kind of
focus and go the extra mile is in
certain respects a secret weapon and
I've had to learn the hard way that is a
very unsustainable source of energy that
leads to burnout that you know unduly
fatigues me and that ultimately makes me
a difficult person to be around and
generally unhappy and so although
there's a dopamine charge that comes
with that that's very addictive having
to learn a new way of approaching my
work that's more balanced
that that involves more equanimity to
use your word has been a challenge but
ultimately is leading me in the
direction of of creating a more
sustainable productive way of
approaching what I do so a number of
things to say about that I mean you just
articulated a psychology that I run into
a lot and one that I dealt with
personally as I was adopting this
practice you're not wrong the the will
that you describe the great that you
describe the motivation creativity has
been a secret weapon for you I mean you
look at what you've achieved that that
doesn't happen just by being you know
perfectly economist in the face of
everything that arises you know like you
you've got it you've got to have some
get up and go and you have it and that
has worked to your advantage at some
point there is diminishing returns and
the self-awareness you generate through
meditation can help you see
okay so mmm the 97th time I launch into
a perseveration loop around the audio
quality on that last podcast does that
does it make anything might help is this
use them this is useful probably not if
you notice you know to spend a little
time worrying about whatever issue
you're worrying about makes sense take
action do what you can to fix it let it
go move on to the next thing that kind
of rabbit hole of useless rumination
just wears down your energy wears down
your resiliency makes you unpleasant to
be around
none of which gets you further towards
your goal but meditation again the self
awareness the mindfulness that we
generate in meditation which can help
you pull yourself out of the nosedive is
what allows you to have a more balanced
effective approach but that is not to
say that stress has no you know has no
role I think if you want to do anything
great plotting and planning wringing of
hands is part of the deal and you
mentioned before the the scope of my
personal responsibilities my
professional responsibilities it does
create anxiety for me and there are time
in the writing of this book I talk about
in the reading the
but my wife had to do a little
intervention because I was just totally
burnt out I was trying to write a book
on top of everything else I was doing in
it I just took it too hard too fast too
far and and she had to take me aside and
be like dude you can't like fall asleep
with the pages of the book you know in
your hand and then have McCobb stressed
dreams as a consequence and that made a
big difference but so just goes to the
final point I wanted to make as it
pertains to to you which is that you you
talked about how you're you know you're
sort of moving in the direction of
having a more balanced approach I would
just give yourself credit because you
can't snap your fingers and just have
the idyllic balanced approach that you
have in your mind it's gonna be about
kind of vectoring toward it and having
failures along the way and then learning
from those failures so you're doing the
thing it's just it's always going to be
a messy process yeah it's definitely
messy yeah yeah and I'm sure if your
wife was here we would get a whole story
about how messy it is but that's cool
that is absolutely cool because there is
no other way to do it
hmm the other objection that I really
connected with is this idea it's one of
the ones ladder in the book later in the
book you know Blanc is my meditation
like you know everybody it's like as an
athlete like I've I've been that guys
like Trail runnings my meditation or
when I'm out on my bike that's my
meditation and I would imagine there's
other people who you know Oh Netflix you
know when I get home at night that's my
meditation and it took me a long time to
understand and I think we talked about
this when I was on your podcast the
difference between there is a meditative
aspect to some of the training that I do
but that's not meditation proper that
there is a qualitative distinction
between an active meditation or an
activity that is meditative and formal
meditation practice can I just say that
when you were on my podcast that was one
of the most popular podcast we've ever
done oh cool thanks man you're the man
so yes we men - what you just said I
hear all the time for people you know
knitting is my meditation or running
running is the big one I hear running as
my meditation yoga is my meditation my
answer to that is always maybe you know
I mean I can't rule it out but
mindfulness meditation is a specific
thing mindfulness meditation is paying
attention to whatever you're doing so
would you step back for a second running
yoga knitting any of these things can be
mindfulness meditation but you have to
do it in a specific way which is to pay
full attention to what's happening so if
you're knitting you're feeling that the
weight of the whatever I don't know how
to knit but the little chopsticks that
you hold while you knit you're feeling
the weight of them you're feeling the
movement you're making conscious
movements and then when you get
distracted which you will a million
times start again and again and again
mindful running would be and I've done
this it's actually hurts much more than
running the normal way where you're you
know rehearsing some argument what you
want to hurl at your boss or you're
listening to a podcast or music but
mindful running is headphones out you're
feeling the physical sensations of the
movement the pounding of your feet the
wind on your face then when you get
distracted you start again
same thing with yoga most people don't
do the aforementioned activities in the
way I just described them they do it
they're letting their minds run hither
and yon by the way that's not a bad
thing I think running and knitting and
yoga all have really important health
and psychological benefits just the way
you've always done them but I wouldn't
call them mindfulness meditation unless
you you add on the tweak that I just
yeah if you if you bring that level of
intentionality to any action activity
that you're participating in then I
suppose yeah it could be but if you're
just going like I'm running and my
mind's is doing whatever it's doing
without giving it any thought or putting
any of that intention into it and
that's not meditation doesn't mean it's
not a good thing to do right it's just
not meditating right right right so we
haven't divided times as somebody who is
in the news and is your career is about
kind of navigating the daily cycle of
insanity that we're all immersed in I
I'm interested in your thoughts of how
to help how to how to kind of navigate
and deal with the day in day out you
know cycle of news that I think is
making people crazy yeah so I I think
there are a number of ways in which
meditation can be useful now one is use
of social media so the self awareness
that's generated through meditation can
help you see when you're just like oh
I've been on Twitter for four hours and
my stomach is upset and I you know my
chest is buzzing and you know I'm just
vibrating with rage that that is a
signal like if you're tuned into those
signals that it's time to step away the
other I had that not to interrupt no but
I was I just have that experience
yesterday I got all caught up in the
Jake Tapper Stephen Miller interview
saga I went down the rabbit hole and
like watched the video and read the
articles and then read the articles
about what happened off camera stuff and
I got really agitated by the whole thing
and I had to finally say like what why
am I even doing this to myself like what
am i what value am I getting out of
engaging and learning about this I think
you got some value because it's
important to be an engaged citizen and
then the mindfulness your training
kicked in and you saw that you had reach
the point of diminished returns and you
pulled yourself up textbook application
of mindfulness so that's one example of
how mindfulness can help in the current
atmosphere the other is when we're
experiencing the kind of rage
frustration helplessness hopelessness
many of us feel in the face of current
events we can those emotions can drive
us to do a lot of them you know
unhealthy things stress eating snapping
at people so the kind of again back to
the self-awareness to know when you're
super angry because there's something
you saw on the news this morning and
you're carrying it out through the rest
of your day and you know in your case
maybe eating too many cacao nibs or
whatever it is you vegans eat I was by
the way is planning on bringing you a
green smoothie but I got all caught up
in my crisis and couldn't make that have
you changed my life because you probably
have your cookbook and if not
infrequently we'll dive in and plant
power way right but also you told me one
day I mean you after you came to my
office the first time we met you I was
hungry and you you a kind of my office
to interview me for the podcast and I
didn't even know who you were
now I was no you are and you said go get
a smoothie with kale spinach banana
blueberry in almond milk and I went and
it was like this is delicious it sounds
disgusting but it's actually totally
delicious you see a ton of energy
sometimes I'll add an avocado so yeah so
instead of binging on food or snapping
at your you know venting your spleen at
your opinionated uncle meditation can
help you sort of not let not be so
buffeted by the the sort of noxious
nature of our political age and then the
third thing is let me just ask you this
though have you noticed a change in
Europe as somebody who's like did you're
in the you're in this as much as anybody
in the world right have you noticed a
difference in how you process that
information or the kind of news diet
that you put yourself on or how you
react to the the vicissitudes of the
cycle so the truth is that I'm more
tuned into the news than I've ever been
and I find myself I'm really following
this story and I'm very concerned very
concerned about the polarization and I'm
very concerned with lots of things but
mostly the biggest problem the root of
it
for me is how we're at each other's
throats and we can't even agree on a
basic set of facts
that's a frame the discussion and that
is so unhealthy there's a total
breakdown and our ability to communicate
in a healthy way yes so I would say that
leads me to the third benefit and
actually there's one more so for the
third benefit is that I think
mindfulness again the self-awareness
that you get through meditation can help
you see your own biases and it's
actually something satisfying about
noticing oh yeah
are you happy every time mother appears
to be making a moving closer to the
white house or conversely do you have a
coffee mug emblazoned with the words
liberal tears on the side of it you know
are you how talking are you like yeah
are you a tribal and are you part of the
problem I think we are all part of the
problem and if you can start to see that
then you can do what I would recommend
and what I have come to do which is to
have a really varied media diet and so I
consume the mainstream media the
so-called mainstream media including ABC
New York Times but also I listen the
liberal podcasts and I was in a
conservative podcast and I find that
seeing the world you know you can go
from listening to Morning Joe to listen
to ben shapiro
and it's like you you're in a different
universe and but it's i think that's
very healthy and seeing and seeing where
your own biases are can be just as
interesting as catching yourself on as
that you described earlier catching
yourself online at the supermarket
justifying how you need to be using
tweeter twitter the this can be a rich
field for exploration and then the
fourth area that i think meditation can
help is the loving-kindness meditation
which we've just kind of discussed which
is basically there's this other form of
meditation that's often taught in
conjunction with mindfulness where you
systematically cultivate good vibes you
sit close your eyes and envision people
you know somebody you're close with
somebody you don't like so a neutral
person etc etc and you send them
silently these phrases like may you be
happy may you be live with ease etc etc
it sounds like Valentine's Day
with a gun to your head and it is super
annoying at the beginning but there's a
there is a lot of science that suggests
that not only does it have a lot of
health benefits but that actually can
change behavior kids preschoolers who
were taught loving-kindness meditation
are more likely to give their stickers
away to kids they don't know having a
preschooler at home I as a big deal and
so I think at this point in time in fact
I think my next book is gonna be about
these practices and they the title that
I'm working on is 10% nicer and the
subtitle is the self-interested case for
not being a dick and there is a
self-interested case that when think
about this when you hold the door open
for somebody what does that feel like in
your mind if you're paying attention it
feels good that is scalable compassion
generosity kindness these are skills
that you can work on and would make a
huge difference in the age in which we
find ourselves right now yes
selflessness when perpetrated from fur
for selfish reasons only still work yes
yeah it does it's a beautiful thing
because somebody like me who's not
naturally altruistic if you turn it into
if you show me the science that suggests
you could live longer you could be
happier you could be more popular and
more successful which is what the
science suggests about kind people if
you show me that science and then you
give me some practices even if they are
a little annoying I will do them because
my motivation is that I want the the
popular happier healthier thing I want
all those things right it's so it's so
counterintuitive and it and it goes
against all the messaging that work
constantly it's supposed to which is
that our happiness is Wed to you know
getting the Tesla or the new house or
being able to go on this vacation when
in truth it's completely accessible by
extending yourself selflessly to another
human being and by the way I got nothing
against the Tesla like I would love to
have it I would love to - that's why I
always use it as an example because I'm
thinking about it too much so so that
isn't to engage in a whole self
flagellation cycle around that it's just
to see that actually on a
moment-to-moment basis the happiness
being kind to yourself and others he's
perennial e available and did you try it
out you know don't take my word for it
that's the way the boot the Buddha's
approach was like don't take my word for
it I'll teach you a bunch of things go
and do it test it in the laboratory of
your own experience and so I'm just
telling you I've tried it it does work
doesn't mean I'm never an [ __ ]
because I'm definitely still an [ __ ]
time at times but when you're mindful
enough you can see what does it feel
like when you're an [ __ ] feels like
[ __ ] and that powerfully disincentivizes
you you know powerfully does
incentivizes you yeah
all right well we got to wrap this up in
a second here but but before we do that
what are you like what are you working
on now like what is emotionally like
what is what's your biggest stumbling
block or what isn't you know what's what
comes up for you in your practice as a
recurring issue that you need to like
work through the biggest change to my
practice came from Jeff Warren my
co-author diagnosing in the course of
spending 11 days of this tin-can
traveling across the country together he
diagnosed that I have a lot of inner
antagonism that I have the potential
that while I can be an [ __ ]
externally most of it is self-directed
and that my meditation practice had a
had a real grim quality as a consequence
that as I discussed this earlier that
I'm always telling people you know when
you get distracted it's no big deal but
when I got distracted like I you know
somehow I was operating on this theory
that I'll win it meditation I'll never
get distracted and then I was blending
yes type-a yeah yeah what didn't what a
schmuck and so I was engaged in all this
self laceration internally and Jeff
helped me inject a huge dose of sunshine
into my practice by he had an idea that
I thought was really cheesy and I
rejected it like I do with all good
ideas initially I'm like the anti blink
you know blink is about the wisdom of
our our you know
rapidfire my my rapid-fire intuitions
always off so Jeff's idea was look when
anger arises for you internally like
name it after your [ __ ] grandfather
Robert Johnson who you got it from so
when it arises be like hey what's up
Robert and and I thought that is dumb
that is corny but after a while I
started to realize actually and this is
because Jeff pointed out to me there are
five or six kind of neurotic programs
that are are always running for all of
us that are running that sort of compete
for salience in your mind at any given
time so for me
anger logistical planning ambition
writing like creativity and there are a
few more and I forgotten them right now
but I gave them names
so like goofy little names like so
Robert Johnson for anger Sammy for my
ambition after the book what makes Sammy
run which is about an ambitious
Hollywood type Julie the cruise director
for Julie after Julie the cruise
director for the love boat for the
logistician Arthur which sounds like
author for every time I'd like to do
some writing in my head and D
personalizing it in that way making it
lighter and literally saying the words
welcome to the party when I see the
arising of these neurotic patterns has
just lowered the temperature in such a
constructive way and it's made me see
that all the sappy talk about being kind
to yourself you have to be kind use of
blah blah blah which I also dismissed is
totally true and that my whole
meditation practice is to become a much
more congenial place I'm gonna close my
eyes to meditate you know and I see I
actually sometimes smile when I see my
anger come up or when I see you know my
ambition overtaking me and I'm carried
off on this train of you know planning
world domination through meditation like
oh my god I see there's pleasure in
seeing it and so Jeff is that Jeff is
Jeff is a hedonist
and I lacked hedonism in my practice and
now I have it and there's a massive gift
that he's given to me even though as I
write about in the book there were many
times when we wanted to murder each
other right well I would imagine part of
that derives from the fact that now you
know for better or worse like your the
meditation guy like that that's how
people see you and I'm sure people stop
you on the street and say hey it's a
meditation dude you know and and and the
pressure that that probably you know
puts on you a little bit too you know
kind of monitor your behavior and like
well if you freak out and get angry at
somebody you know how do you how do you
like you know walk your talk and in the
best way possible is can be without you
know it could be like an unhealthy
relationship that you have with yourself
yeah it could be though I think frankly
for me wasn't really that it was just it
was just this I have this conditioning
then that veers me toward anger right
you know my grandfather Robert Johnson's
a real person and not a nice dude Oh
later in his life he actually became
very nice but most of his life I
remember one time he in the 80s or
something like that he got his first VCR
and I took me in my little brother and
to see it and he said if you touch this
I'll break your arm that was the you
know that was the kind of dude he was
and like I have Robert Johnson in my
veins and like and there have been many
times in my life and to this day where I
am capable of very cutting comments and
most of it though is self-directed and
Jeff just saw that in me you know
there's a benefits being locked up on a
bus with a brilliant meditation teacher
interesting [ __ ] that you may not want
to face will be dragged out of your
subconscious and and and presented to
you and that's what happened I like that
idea of giving all of these qualities
names though and recognizing that they
exist rather than trying to deny their
you know that they're there even or it's
certain it reminds me of Elizabeth
Gilbert right
she wrote about this in her book big
magic yeah for that but like she when
you go on a creative endeavor you know
your your whatever that voice is that
talks you out of your self-worth not
particularly to not pretend that it
doesn't exist like okay we're going on
this road trip you can come but you got
to sit in the backseat and you can't
pick the music and you can't tell you
can't give directions yeah it's just
similar idea the the the weapon may not
be the right word it's like a nerf
weapon you know the sort of non-violent
weapon we are equipping you with here
through meditation is just seeing
clearly when you see this stuff it can
tone you and so there are all these
little techniques that we use you know
and and coming up with goofy names for
your inner dramatis persona is one of
these techniques you don't have to do it
but I've found it to be very useful and
bringing it back to the book you know in
terms of techniques
I mean it's broken down in such
simplistic terms like you know anybody
can do this I mean literally there is if
you read this book you will learn how to
meditate and you will you it will be so
accessible and so you know easy to
incorporate into your life and I think
that's one of the great kind of like
gifts of this message that you put forth
in the new book Thank You Man I
appreciate that because the you have
like these chapters but then you break
it down at the end and like here's the
here's how we're doing it and it's like
oh that's a very elementary like I get
it completely it doesn't have to be some
major ordeal where you're giving me two
hundred things to think about and tasks
to do it's just very simple that's that
was the goal I mean it was very hard to
get there but that was the goal
make it as user-friendly as possible
simple simple simple and also tell you
an engaging story in the process right
so for somebody who's now listen to us
for 90 minutes and is thinking all right
I'm sold I'm onboard
other than getting your app and getting
a new book what's a way to just launch
into this and again look the
okay this is gonna make me the worst
shittiest businessman of all time I will
I love selling books I love having
people subscribe to the app but the
basic constructions are really amazing
you know
sit in a reasonably quiet place close
your eyes if you don't like having your
eyes closed you can kind of keep them
open just a little bit and stare at a
neutral spot on the floor second step is
to just bring your full attention to the
feeling of your breath coming in and
going out pick a spot where it's most
prominent your nose your chest your
belly the third step is the most
important because as as soon as you try
to do this your mind is going to go
crazy you have all sorts of random
thoughts where the gerbils run wild
whatever blob but what kind of bird was
big bird whatever blah blah blah and
then the whole game is just to notice
when you become distracted start again
and again and again those are the
instructions this is the way they've
been doing it for millennia you don't
need a book you don't need an app you
just need your mind and your breath and
a reasonably quiet place and if it's not
quiet just put some headphones on you
could do that one minute a day truly one
minute daily ish so like most days and I
think you'd start deriving a lot of the
benefits that we've discussed from
meditation it helps to have support in
the form of a teacher if you like to go
to a local class or an app where you
have a bunch of teachers like ours or
there are lots of other good apps as
well also makes me a shitty business man
but it's true or reading a good book
these can all be very helpful tools but
the basic instructions are just what I
just described so just play that back to
yourself and go sit for a minute and do
it set a timer on your phone and go do
it good talking to dad always a pleasure
a huge pleasure Thank You Man appreciate
for doing it that was awesome
definitely pick up the new book
meditation for fidgety skeptics download
the app the 10% happier app available
wherever you get your apps listen to the
podcast September you've done a good job
with branding here yep podcast and you
know turn your television on and you're
sure to catch him on ABC 10 and Dan B
Harris on Twitter right and yes
website 10% happier dr. Tom yeah there
you go
here we go alright man thanks how can
you like buzz peace peace namaste
namaste
peace is why is it pains you Jesus day
you